قال رئيس البيلاروسي اليكساندر لوكاشينكو
في مقابله مع تلفزيون الصينيه رسميا
العقوبات الغربيه على الشعب البيلاروسي
كشفت له اعدائه من اصدقائه وفق تعبيره
واكد لوكاشينكو خلال زياره رسميه الى
بيجين على علاقه بلاده الوثيقه مع الصين
لقد كنا اصدقاء موثوقين للشعب الصيني على
مدى العقود القليله الماضيه وسنظل كذلك في
المستقبل لقد راى شعبنا خاصه عندما يعاني
من عقوبات من الدول الغربيه بوضوح من هم
اعدائنا ومن هم اصدقائنا
اسمك
ما الذي تحميله زياره لوكاشينكو الحليفه
الوثيق
لروسيا الى الصين
وهكذا يقراها الغرب وسيله هنالك وسائل
اعلام رسميه صينيه تتحدث عن ان الغرب يقرا
الزياره على ان بيلاروسيا هي حليف وثيق
لروسيا ويقوم بزياره الى الصين الرئيس
البيلاروسيه
مع دخول الازمه الاوكرانيه عام الثاني لكن
الجانب الصيني كان قد رفض رفضا قاطعا مثل
هذه القراءه واكد على ان العلاقات التي
تربط بين مينسك وبيجيه علاقات ثنائيه
وثيقه علاقات تعاون وشراكه اقتصاديه عميقه
قبل يعني تمتد على سنوات طويله قبل بدايه
الصراع في اوكرانيا بالتالي هنالك رفض من
الجانب الرسمي الصيني ومن وسائل الاعلام
الحكوميه لمثل هذا الربط بين زياره
لوكاشينكو وتعزيز ربما العلاقه بين الصين
وحلفاء روسيا من جهه وبين الصين وروسيا من
جهه اخرى امام حربها المتواصله على
اوكرانيا اليوم اجتمع الكسندر لوكاشينكو
الرئيس بيلاروسي برئيس مجلس الدوله الصيني
في القاعه في قاعه الشعب الكبرى وايضا
اجتمع
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين وهنالك ايضا
اجتماعات مرتقبه اليوم او يوم غد بين
لوكاشينكو والرئيس الصيني شجيم خاصه وانه
يؤدي زياره الى الصين تلبيه لدعوى رسميه
من الرئيس الصيني قبل انتهاء الزياره يوم
غد الجانب الصيني كان قد اكد حتى قبل وصول
لوكاشينكو الى الصين على اهميه العلاقه
واواصر الصداقه التي تربط بين بيجين ومسك
وذلك خلال اتصال هاتفي تحدثت عنه وسائل
الاعلام الحكوميه الصينيه بين وزير
الخارجيه الصيني قبل ايام من زياره
لوكاشينكو مع نظيره البيلاروسي الذي اكد
خلاله الوزير الصيني بان الصمت لاهميه
كبيره لتعزيز العلاقات مع الجانب
البيلاروسي اكدت ايضا بان الزياره الثالثه
عشر ليلو كاشينكو للصين لها اهميه كبيره
في توطيد التبادلات التجاريه والاقتصاديه
مع الصين بعد انتهاء ازمه كورونا على
العالم وايضا اكد الجانب الصيني للجانب
البيلاروسي بان الصين تولي اهميه كبيره
لما يعانيه الشعب البيلاروسي على حسب
وصفها من التبعات العقوبات الغربيه عليهم
بان الصين طولي ايضا اهميه
لمعانات الشعب البيلاروسي وتقف الى جانب
مسك فيما تعانيه من العقوبات الغربيه
المسلطه عليها اهميه كبيره ايضا تليها
يوليها الجانب البيلاروسي راينا ذلك من
خلال تصريحات الرئيس البلوروسي اليوم
للاعلام المحلي الرسمى الصيني وهنالك
توقعات بتوقيع شراكات واتفاقيات بين
الجاني بين اليوم او في وقت مبكر من يوم
غد لتعزيز الشركات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه
بين الجانبين والسير شكرا جزيلا لك شيماء
مراسله من